oh
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
I'm happy to talk about both things I've
been involved in and other kinds of
history that I might happen to know
about you know I am right now uh
submerged in a crazy history project
because I done some work on the second
law of thermodynamics
um which is a 150 year old thing I think
I mentioned this before I really managed
to make I think some pretty nice
progress that lets one understand a
bunch of things
that uh is made possible Now by things
that have come out of our physics
project but I myself have been
interested in the second orthodynamics
basically since I was 12 years old which
is like 50 something years ago and
um uh I've been trying to now as part of
writing up what I've done and
understanding of the Dynamics recently I
decided I should write kind of the Arc
of the whole story 50 years story of my
uh involvement with the second world of
thermodynamics and it's interesting I
mean
history is hard uh you know this is
self-history so you know sort of I've
lived all these pieces and yet what I
realized as I try to write that history
is that there are many connections which
sort of on the ground at the moment I
did not understand and only decades
later can you sort of fit those threads
together and see why one it was sort of
obvious one went from here to there the
thing that's also notable to me about
this history is there are sort of long
periods where not a lot seem to happen
and then moments where in just a couple
of days having discovered something I
could work out its consequences because
I kind of knew the context and it was
sort of immediately things unrolled and
that's the case on um
uh May 26 to June 1st 1984 was uh a big
sort of flurry of Discovery around rule
30.
um which I think I may have mentioned
this before I I now have tracked this
down you know I first made a rule 30
and England included in a paper in 1982
in early 1982
but I included it essentially without
comment like I didn't really internalize
this phenomenon that you can have such a
simple rule simple initial conditions
complicated Behavior it took me two more
years to internalize that but once I got
to it I had figured out things like
computational reducibility very quickly
thereafter because I had sort of
precursors of that from studying
complicated initial conditions but you
know the process that I've been doing
I'm now I'm now up to 1986.
in my attempt to kind of Trace down this
history and it's sort of you know how
does one really do this well I have good
archives they're reasonably organized
but not perfectly organized some of the
issues are
um that there are documents which are
undated where it's hard to know what
order they go in I don't have my
archives organized I don't have a purely
chronological organization of my
archives and I that's something we're
trying to build some some technology and
software for doing archive work and one
of the things I want to try to do is
have something where using whatever
heuristics we can and whatever actual
dates are available
um to actually be able to get everything
in the archive organized chronologically
um that would be quite useful to see but
you know for me uh it turns out even the
80s I was doing sort of multi I led a
multi-threaded life where I was doing
lots of different things at the same
time technology development science
organizational kinds of things and so on
and so it isn't the case that there's
sort of a single block of when oh this
was happening then this was happening
it's all interwoven with other but with
other things I mean for example I have
my calendars from 1983 84 85 Etc and
I've been spending I've had to go back
and just look you know what what was I
actually doing on these on these dates
and I have all that information
um and you know I'm trying to figure out
when did I receive this letter well you
know I can figure out it was a physical
letter because everything was in those
days and I was traveling those days so I
couldn't received it then it must have
been when I got back which was this
particular date
and you know for example I just found um
uh a FedEx something which was a pile of
documents where they've been scanned but
they were in an envelope but it was a
FedEx envelope so I kind of knew it had
to have a FedEx air Bill and that was
from 1985. I'm somewhat amused at how
incredibly similar the early FedEx air
bill from 1985 looks to a federal today
but be that as of May one thing that's
useful about that has got a date on it
and so then one knows what when that
stack of documents is from but this
question about dating things I've also
got my file systems and often one can
get a date from file systems from the uh
most recent modification date on the
files that's fine but what if there was
an earlier version of it and how does
one find out when was the file first
created sometimes there are file systems
that have that information the Unix file
system that doesn't store that
information I think at least the version
of it that existed back in those days it
just stores the most recent modification
date and so then I have for example I
have tapes nine track tape Magnetic Tape
uh which and we've read most of the
tapes that I had backup tapes that I had
from the 1980s
um and so one can see there some of
those things there are also cases where
there are um backup manifests that were
on a particular date someone can see
whether a file had been created by that
date and so on I mean it's surprisingly
complicated to to track down sort of uh
some of these threads of what happened
when like for example the particular
thing that I uh sort of was up to late
yesterday trying to figure out is in
1986
I found sort of minimal cellular
automaton approximations the diffusion
equation which is something where the
things I found I have now reused in the
stuff I'm doing right now on the second
world thermodynamics
and the question is I know that I
presented those things as a poster at a
conference called CA 86 it's a little
automaton conference at MIT that I was
the main organizer of
um and uh
the um uh and I've got sort of the the
both the bile raw material and the scans
of the poster
um that I had but then there was sort of
how did I actually do the search for
this rule
um I have code that could have done that
search but I haven't yet found the
actual place where I did you know it
probably searched a billion different
rules
um I haven't found that actual search
and and maybe there's no tangible output
of it anymore maybe I just had a file
that was here's the things I found
um and you know that's an example of
something where I'd kind of like to know
how big was that search was it something
where I had to go and use some fancy
network of computers was it something I
could just do on the single workstation
class computer that I had at that time
which was then the sun workstation
um it's uh it's I I'm sort of trying to
track those things down
and uh anyway that this process of doing
what we might call computational history
I find it's interesting because one
really has a tremendous amount of detail
uh but sometimes it has to sort of
thread things together in complicated
ways and one has to go uh searching for
things and I suppose one of the things
I've noticed here is that I think I'm
I'm um
uh there's a different way you read
things when you're doing things for
history as when you're doing things on
the ground so there are documents that I
have sometimes from other people
sometimes letters and so on where I'm
like yeah I think I know what that
letter said and then I'm like well I'm
doing history now let me actually read
every word of this letter and I realize
oh my gosh I didn't read that part
because I don't really care about that
part at the time but that's relevant for
piecing together the kind of historical
thread
well
okay let's let's go to some of the
questions people have here after after
that um
um
blank is asking do you think
in the future people will look at our
societal interests in math and science
the same way we view Alchemists and
theologians of old
that's an interesting question
I think the Alchemists and the
theologians got kind of a bad rap
I think
what happened is
such a very interesting question
okay
in a lot of fields there are things they
can do and there are things they cannot
do
and
when
the things they can do are value but
sometimes they overdrive themselves and
they end up pushing into things that
they can't do
and then if that takes over the field
then they get kind of a bad reputation
so for the Alchemists there was plenty
of good work that was done on what we
would Now call Chemistry Metallurgy
things like this but then there was the
the thing that is kind of the poster
goal of the Alchemists of turning lead
into gold that just didn't work and
there was lots of Hocus Pocus done under
the brand of alchemy
um but there was also lots of perfectly
sensible chemistry that was done under
the brand of alchemy and I think this is
one of these cases where if it had just
been oh were you just doing this
chemistry we're learning how to refine
these oars we're doing this kind of
thing it'd be like that's great Alchemy
is great but Alchemy overran Itself by
saying we're going to turn lead into
gold
so now the question is if you look at
modern science unfortunately modern
science is in some cases overrunning
itself it says we can predict exactly
what's going to happen in you know
pandemic situation X
in I don't know uh climate situation why
these kinds of things it's like we're
doing science we can predict all these
things well it turns out one can't and
by over by over promising science will
end up defeating itself now there's you
know the the collection of things that
have been well achieved by science is
very large very important for the
Technology and Engineering we've done
and so on but nevertheless science uh
for reasons that are uh both of its own
internal pride and for sort of the
societal forces on it
uh it has a habit of over over promising
and the question is will it be the case
that people will look at for example
some of the things that people have said
we can prove it scientifically in the
21st century in the early 21st century
and people will look at that in the
future and laugh at it and say that was
just silly just as we say looking at the
Alchemists the idea that they could turn
that into gold was silly yes I think
that will probably happen I think that
uh whether the brand of current modern
mathematical science is
um is that tainted is unclear to me
um I think there's I think that it's had
so much mileage of positive stuff that I
think the taint will not be that large
although I do think that some degree of
you know it's been proved scientifically
type thing
um will be people will just roll their
eyes type thing just like people would
have said uh you know at some moment the
the theologians will have said you know
it works this way because it's written
that way in such and such a a sacred
book or whatever else and there came a
time in the modern times when at least
some fraction of the population sort of
rolls their eyes at that and says no it
isn't true you know just because it says
in Genesis or one can deduce some
Genesis that the Earth was created six
thousand years ago you know people then
roll their eyes and say that's not true
type thing
um it's uh and so similarly there will
be things where people have said today
we've proved scientifically that XYZ is
true and in the future people will roll
their eyes at that and say how could
they have said that that was just silly
because they there was just so much they
didn't understand I think a big piece of
that and something related to my own
work is this idea of computationally
reducibility this idea that even though
you might know the rules by which a
system operates knowing how that system
will actually behave is something that
requires an arbitrarily large amount of
computation and so to say yes yes we
know how these sort of microscopic
pieces of transmission of some disease
or something work therefore we can
deduce this whole thing about the whole
story or some similar thing in in
medicine or biomedicine or whatever that
just because we know the rules means we
can immediately deduce the whole story
that's just not true that's a case where
from within science we know from
computational irreducibility that just
knowing the rules is not the whole story
of working out the consequences and I
think there will be met plenty of cases
where people say in the future if they'd
only really understood computational
irreducibility they wouldn't have said
something that silly they wouldn't have
said oh we know how the rules work
therefore we can immediately deduce this
result
so in in much the same way that people
might have said you know in the past uh
oh
you know because it's written in such
and such a book that this is true we'll
just believe that even though uh without
sort of doing what we would now see as
being sort of a scientific validation of
that claim no it's worth remembering
that I think the history of of sort of
the scientific method and so on the
baconian kind of thing I think Francis
Bacon I think was an advisor to
Elizabeth the first if I remember
correctly and was more a politician than
scientist and in his original conception
of sort of let's present this as a
scientific fact part of that original
conception was let's do it that way so
people would argue about it so we can
just say it's science you can prove it
scientifically you don't have to have a
debate about it
um and I think that that's uh uh you
know that story of let's be
authoritative where scientists here uh
you know it
um
uh
um is is something that that existed
from the very earliest days of kind of
this concept of the scientific method
and that has the habit of causing
science to sort of overclaim itself and
that will cause trouble so yes I think
that um uh
um
now
you know in terms of the view of of
Science and Mathematics from today
there's plenty that will survive there's
some that will not
if we talk about theology for example uh
it's sort of interesting because
theology you know starting in the 1600s
basically was sort of overtaken by
science and mathematical science in
particular
um and people started saying uh well we
can we can just use science to know the
answer to this we don't use the the kind
of the intellectual structure of
theology
I think one of the things that's
happened with our physics project and
other such things is a lot of these
questions from where does the universe
exist on down so to speak end up cutting
their way all the way through what we
know from the last 300 years of science
back to questions which were more the
the kind of the purview of the
theologians and so some of those kinds
of intellectual structures that were
built at the time some of them I think
you know it don't seem very convincing
anymore but there was plenty of of deep
intellectual structure that was built
about sort of The Logical consequences
of certain kinds of assumptions which
science and the mathematical tradition
had no great use for but which now I
think we have much more useful so I
think there's sort of more respect is
due to some of the intellectual
structures built by theologians maybe
500 000 years ago than um or more
um than than perhaps they were given
after sort of the next wave of
popularity came in I mean it's it's like
I it's hard to predict but I can imagine
a uh a sort of a wave of things where
people say look you know we've already
got to the point where we're using
programs to describe a lot of kinds of
processes rather than equations I can
believe that there will come a point
where computational irreducibility is
kind of the thing that people come to
associate with the next thing beyond the
science we have now I I hate to call it
um as I ended up calling my big book 20
years ago a new kind of science but
that's um that's what one is really
talking about there a kind of science
that is deeply informed by computational
reducibility and I can imagine a time
when that kind of science looks back on
our computational reducible science and
says those guys thought they could
figure out a lot more with the sort of
computationally reducible science than
they could and they did a bunch of goofy
things like The Alchemist did and so on
let's see all right lots of interesting
questions here
um
well hello roll asks tell us about the
history of Chess computers and
approaches they used before deep
learning
I can say a little bit about that I
don't know it in tremendous detail
um
the
even back
you know the idea of clockwork automata
was already in in the 1600s people
already had sort of clockwork and and
cogs and machines and and so on and
people started talking about making
chess playing automata
all the way back in those kinds of times
a sort of A Clockwork automata I mean
famously The Mechanical Turk as it
became known was supposed to be a chess
playing machine I guess from the 1700s
maybe maybe the early 1800s that was a
thing that went on tour so to speak as
look there's this box and you can play
chess with it and of course it had a a
small stature person inside it who was
really the the chess player doing that
and that's what led to the sort of the
the term Mechanical Turk so to speak
um that uh
uh is some I I guess the the the
um uh the sort of purveyor of the box
was Turkish probably
um so that was sort of an early
non-example
then
when electronic computers came in
uh people started pretty early talking
about Chess playing I mean Alan Turing
talked about Chess playing a person
called David champanone who was a a
friend of Alan turing's um at King's
College Cambridge
um and David Chapman went on to become a
fairly distinguished Economist
um but when those two were sort of in
college they were talking about building
chess playing computers and I think
Turing got a certain distance in kind of
speccing out how you would use in those
days it was kind of electromechanical
relay based computers of the kind that
had really been introduced for things
like telephone switching I mean that was
the technology the the bombs and bombe's
at Bletchley Park used for code breaking
were originally that technology was all
switching technology that had come from
the from the telephone system
um of uh being able to just sort of
switch lines to connect in different
ways based on dialed numbers and so on
so I think then
after that the uh I don't know
um
let's see I don't think I know what
happened until the 70s it wasn't that
far from the from the 1950s so I don't
think I know what happened in the 1960s
with chess playing computers
um do I know uh
Yes actually I do know something about
that so I mean in the early kind of
discussions of AI
sort of Chess playing was one of the
branches of what was discussed and a big
piece of sort of early 1960s so-called
artificial intelligence had to do with
searching strategies and the question of
sort of how do you prune the search
because let's say you're doing chess and
you say well what move am I going to
make what you really want to do is to
enumerate many possible moves that sort
of tree out these possible moves and say
if I do this then the opponent does this
if I do that can you go five moves out
for example and say what will happen if
I take if I make this move uh what will
happen if I make that move how do I
score these different things that will
be the outcomes of those different moves
Etc in modern times I would talk about
this is a multi-way graph
um in fact I even wrote something a few
months ago about
um uh multi-way graphs for games I
didn't get to chess a person at our
summer school actually did do look at
chess and games that are rather nice job
looking at that I looked at things like
tic-tac-toe where the full gain graph is
only 5000 nodes or something for chess
the full game graph is you know 10 to
the 100 nodes or whatever
um but so
a lot of sort of the early thinking
about some of the early thinking about
AI had to do with this idea that one's
going to be searching this big space
it's the same thing with theorem proving
you're trying to prove a theorem where
you go from this expression to that
expression by applying axioms and the
question is which set of axioms should
you apply to get from here to there same
thing in chemical synthesis even in the
1960s as a project at Harvard for
example called Lassa lhasa which was a
um an attempt to do chemical synthesis
by using this kind of search and and and
sort of prune the search
today in in automated theorem proving
that's that's what you're doing is
you're you're doing this big branching
set of possibilities and you're finding
better and better ways to prune the
search so that was a thing that was sort
of part of the the AI canon in the in
the early 60s
um probably you know through through the
late 60s
so then
by the 70s
people were starting to talk about
making Uh custom Hardware to do chess
playing because the the it just wasn't
going to be one wasn't going to be able
to get to human level by using pure
software with the computers of the time
and so there was a group at MIT
um I think Ed fredkin was involved in I
think Richard Greenblatt was a big
figure in it
um who were trying to make a um a chess
playing computer and I think Ed fredkin
friend of mine from many years
um put up like a hundred thousand dollar
prize for the first computer that can
beat a grand master at chess
and and the way those those computers
worked it was always you're treeing out
possibilities using heuristics to
determine which branches of the tree are
worth pursuing and keep going from there
so I think uh in and then
the um
the
Deep Blue
Deep Blue
is that the right name oh my gosh
um the chess playing computer from the
1990s that was an IBM kind of uh r d
I wouldn't say publicity stunt but um
you know R D
um uh demonstration let's say uh
was
uh that was again using sort of
classical chess playing methods not what
we would Now call sort of neural net
based machine learning or anything like
that
I think
um
uh meanwhile
the the sort of the the state of the art
of kind of even little pocket you know
chess playing uh devices got better and
better and it's all a question of how
how many moves ahead can you look
effectively and how well can you score
the game the the board positions that
you get to by going by making a series
of moves how can you know oh that's a
total lose for white in this case or
something how do you how do you do those
scorings
so I think that's that's what kind of
got one to the threshold of modern
um chess playing systems and I don't
really know in detail uh how the modern
systems work my guess is that the main
use of deep learning has to do with
again this this you know which path is
worth looking at it's something I've
even looked at a bit in the case of
automated theorem proving can one use
machine learning to uh to guess which
direction you should go and which is a
waste of time it's like if you're
simplifying a mathematical expression is
it worth expanding this piece over here
or crushing this piece over here or is
that oh no that's a bad Branch to go
down go down a different branch can you
can you machine learn what branch is
worth going down and that's I think the
main role there but I don't know in
detail how the modern chess playing
systems work but that's a that's a
little bit of outline of of that term
that history such as I know it
uh
oh wow from Aaron here can I talk about
the history of software packaging and
distribution
that's a fun one one doesn't talk about
very much
um
you know
okay so there are different kinds of
computers there were mainframe computers
the size of a large room there were uh
sort of more mini computers which
actually got called mini computers by
the sometime in the late 70s that were
more the size of a big desk
and then eventually in the end of the
70s beginning of the 80s there started
to be personal computers that were uh
you know Works in different ways each of
these different kinds of machines had
different storage media and different
ways that things were distributed so for
example for
actually I would say that the um
uh the sort of standard distribution
medium
for the the big computers so to speak
was usually nine track magnetic tape so
these big reels of magnetic tape you
know if you look at a 1950s movie or
something that features a computer like
the desk set movie that's a good model
for Wolf Alpha so to speak where where
there's a computer that can be asked
General Knowledge Questions I'm pretty
sure we can do all the ones in that um
uh in that movie
um you know you'll see the computer in
the background it's a IBM probably
Mainframe computer that has all these
tapes that are going to
you know the circular tapes and there'll
be two spools of tape and you'll
continuously see the computer like uh
you know twitching different different
pieces of that tape and what's happening
there I mean what's happening in the
movie who knows but what's happening in
real life in a Mainframe computer is
you're you're trying to seek to a
particular part of the tape to find the
data that's at that part of the tape
so early software distribution was
mostly on magnetic tapes like that that
was the best way to do it
um what happened
when more personal computers started to
come in was floppy disks which were uh
kind of magnetic discs so you know
magnetic tape made of ferrite
um you know it's something like a like a
magnet except that it's broken into
these tiny magnetic domains and those
tiny magnetic domains can be each one
can be independently up or down so
that's how you store the data on the on
the tape or disk you have these disks
and then there were different sizes and
shapes of disks I have many of them in
my in my possession now
um there were
five and a quarter inch discs which
became sort of a standard for the early
personal computers particularly ones
running the CPM operating system that
was a sort of Forerunner of Microsoft
MS-DOS
um the uh uh those were and so a floppy
disk was literally you know it's floppy
it had a sort of a cardboardish
container and inside was this um uh was
this um
um
uh you know typically brownish-colored
um you know magnetic ferrite thing that
was was bendable
um so then what happened in
so the software distribution for
personal computers was on floppy disks
and um
that
really
continued when when Mathematica came out
in 1988
floppy disks were the medium of
distribution for personal computers
initially the mac and later when PCS got
powerful enough a couple of years later
that one could run uh mathematical on
PCS floppy disks was still the
distribution medium and so it's kind of
a dramatic thing you know when we first
um uh were
um we're making Mathematica it was like
uh I mean today when we finished a
version of open language literally it um
uh you know it's done the testing is
finished we have a you know a Master
Copy we pretty much just press go and
people can download it actually in
modern times it goes to a Content
delivery Network and so it takes a few
moments to propagate out to the CDN but
then people can immediately download it
it's sort of an immediate thing but back
in the day that wasn't how it worked
back in the day you would take it to a
disk duplicator and um they would
generate lots and lots of copies so I
remember I think how this duplicator was
somewhere in Minnesota
um and I remember many different
versions where we had deadlines
including the very first version of
Mathematica somebody had to get on a
plane with the master disc and go take
it to the duplicator and then they would
the duplicator would churn out copies
and so on and that will be the
distribution medium for the for personal
computers
for um slightly bigger computers
um workstation class computers uh
usually these cassette tapes not
cassette tapes like in a tape player but
bigger crunchier
um sort of cartridges
um were the thing which had tape inside
them were the distribution medium that
was used there and and there were many
different standards in other words there
weren't any standards really at all
there were lots of different
incompatible in our sun workstation an
HP workstation Apollo workstation they
all use different kinds of tape and so
you actually had to separately copy the
software onto those different kinds of
tape
um
the thing that happened in the floppy
disk world is uh three and a half inch
floppy disks came in the five and a
quarter had been the standard for sort
of the more professional workstation
type things they were even bigger than
five and a quarter inch floppy disks I
don't remember exactly what size I
remember one computer
um actually uh the aforementioned Ed
fredkin was was uh for a while the CEO
of this company a company company called
Three Rivers computer corporation that
made a thing called the perk p-e-r-q
which was an early workstation computer
um that uh didn't in the end do that
well but um it was it was kind of a
um
kind of alongside the sun workstation
the Apollo workstation sort of at the
same time 1982-ish time frame
um and uh
um it for some reason I know had very
big floppy disks because I have a bunch
of them
um and uh kind of absurdly oversized
floppy disks
now in terms of the packaging of these
things of how did you get
you know what were they what were they
put in you know what did the things what
was the outer packaging well actually
much of the other packaging was really
cruddy I mean like for example when you
sent out tapes
there was no out of packaging it was
basically just in an envelope and um the
tape itself would typically have like
copyright information on it and it would
say uh what
um
um what um
uh uh kind of you know what the software
was and so on and um uh and then of
course there wasn't it's not like it had
a URL because it wasn't the web didn't
exist in those days so if you wanted you
know one would have to have actual
booklets that were the installation
booklets that came with these things now
I think
um in terms of kind of nice looking
packaging they were usually cardboard
boxes
um and uh like for example in early uh
in terms of sort of professional
software
most of the packaging was really crummy
and I think we kind of set some kind of
standard with with Mathematica of having
a kind of actual designed graphic design
kind of art for packaging and graphic
design and art for the labels on the
floppy disks and so on
um and that was uh uh that was our you
know late 80s there have been some some
decent some decent packaging now another
big part of the the story and actually I
suppose this relates also to packaging
is in those days there were Corner
software stores and people thought that
was the future just like there'd been
bookstores and you know the local Corner
bookstore so similarly there were the
local Corner software stores and they
were there were companies like um
Egghead software
and oh my gosh what was the Big Chain of
them
oh
comp you something rather I'm not sure I
don't remember
um
and and the way that a lot of software
was was sold is you would literally go
into the software store and you would
buy this box that was the software you
wanted
and uh as as a as a company selling to
these organizations it was um
uh
they were sometimes very squarely
organizations they would have things
like you sell them stuff and it has a
90-day time to pay and they would
routinely send back stuff at day 89 and
reorder it at day 91 and things like
this in order to avoid having to have
any costs to carry the inventory all
sorts of squiggly things like that I
think Egghead software was particularly
was famously the worst at that and a
very um
um oh no there was a was it
as a chap who went by the name of Crazy
Eddie who was somehow involved with that
maybe that was the same organization and
who wound up in in terrible legal
trouble
um uh for various reasons
um but anyway it was a very kind of
weird weird industry
um but along with some very fine um what
was it Compuware was that the name of
one of the chains I remember there was a
a um a lovely software store in Palo
Alto California which was the the very
first place
um well we we had uh made the day that
Mathematica was released June 23 1988
that was some
uh sort of a place where it was going to
be available and literally we were like
delivering the boxes the you know big uh
sort of boxes of software to that place
the night before and so on and then I
think we had a an event there the the
the day after or something like that
um and so there were that was that was a
a sort of a single location store as I
remember
um as opposed to these chains which came
into existence and then then the next
big thing that happened was mail order
software uh stuff and um
that's um uh yeah that that was some and
obviously by the time online delivery of
software became possible after the web I
mean online delivery of material was
possible with FTP once the internet
existed before the web existed but that
wasn't a common way to get uh
most kinds of software
um at least commercial software uh that
was still very much of this we'll send
the tape in the mail so to speak
um
and uh various people commenting here I
remember installing Word Perfect using a
set of three and a half inch disks
yes no I think it in the end and this is
where you know a technology is kind of
losing it the the Mathematica
distribution for uh became like a 13
Disc set so in order to in order to load
up the software you'd be putting in 13
successive floppy disks and and people
yeah that things went to double density
quadruple density floppy disks and um
and then things went to CD-ROMs
and uh and then to DVDs and that was
kind of the the next those next levels
of evolution of software distribution
another very funky thing I have to talk
about this was
um software protection on floppy disks
so back when uh when mathematical was
first coming out
there was a big campaign there's big ads
running everywhere don't copy that
floppy
um which was a an anti-software piracy
thing because it wasn't very well
defined in those days sort of what the
story of intellectual property was for
software and so on and what was copyable
what wasn't it really varied a lot from
country to Country I think the US really
turned the corner sometime in the
probably
mid to late 80s of people expecting that
you know you wanted serious software you
would buy the software
Etc and I mean at the time when uh in
the mid to late 80s Microsoft and
Borland were the two companies and they
were kind of duking it out with
different price points and so on and
Microsoft eventually won at a slightly
higher price point and with different
sorts of expectations I think that um uh
but in other countries there was and in
some countries there still is you know
98 software piracy and things like that
which makes it very hard to uh have you
know much enthusiasm for making
commercial software for such countries
and and what happened in in some
countries is as soon as there was
indigenous software production that
really changed it I remember it changed
in Japan for example as soon as there
was a sort of indigenous Japanese word
processor that have been produced in the
country and and people were like yes
we're buying it it's from a Japanese
company and so on I think that things
really turned around in that case
um in uh
in other cases it's it's uh well we're
still not there
um but anyway back in the 80s one of the
issues was could you just take a floppy
disk and make a copy of it and and
perhaps you know in those days people
had the idea that well you could just
sell the floppy you know you could sell
the copy and uh because people didn't
know about online distribution there
wasn't the issue of sort of online uh
you know where it becomes rather much
more trivial to copy things then people
still had the idea it's like a book you
could photocopy the book well it was a
lot easier to copy the data the software
data on a floppy disk and so on and so
there was this whole vast micro industry
of copy protection
and so there were all these different
schemes for copy protection there were
these so-called dongles where you would
put a a device onto your computer that
had a unique ID then you would call the
software vendor for a for a an a number
to type in that would allow you to um to
run the thing or no actually I'm sorry
I'm sorry dongles you could typically
run you just had the dongle and your
computer the software would look for the
dongle and if it found it it would run
on that computer and if it didn't find
it it wouldn't wouldn't run on that
computer
um and then there were all these schemes
where people would make actual physical
changes to the floppy disks to prevent
them from being copyable and so on and
then there were schemes that were more
more like today with activation codes
and so on that um
um that that were used I I will tell a
story from the early days this is what
early 90s
um from Mathematica one of our
interesting so protection stories was we
had things set up so that uh you'd get
some
ID code to run
um Mathematica on a particular kind of
computer but we'd also look at look at
the computer and if the computer had
certain characteristics it wouldn't run
or at least you had to get a different
version to run on my computer so for
example we had a version that was a
us-based version we had International
versions and we had versions that were
for example suitable for Russian
computers okay so here's the story maybe
I've told this on a live stream before
but it's a good story so and it deserves
being told again so this was a time when
the mer space station was
you know sort of up and about and there
was an American astronaut named Mike foe
who um uh was a user that still is a
user of mathematical from language and
so on
um and uh he uh took
a a a
um a laptop with um with Mathematica
installed to the mer Space Station
well then there was an accident on the
merth space station I believe that
laptop wound up in space
um and uh uh but Mike being a sort of an
efficient astronaut had kept a copy of a
distribution disc somewhere else
separate from the from the laptop and so
and at the time the space station was
was slowly spinning and so the question
was how could you prevent the space
station spinning and Mike again being
sort of an efficient calm astronaut was
like I know the equations of motion I
can just solve those differential
equations in Mathematica and I can work
out you know what happens if we fire
this Thruster and so on you know how do
we stop the space station spinning
so uh so gets out the distribution disc
puts it in the only PC ad available
which was a Russian PC that hadn't been
pulled out into space puts it in it says
sorry I won't run this is a Russian PC
this wasn't a uh a version of um of
Mathematica made for for Russian PCS
so then our customer service team gets
some call from some ground control
person saying you know uh what do we do
about this and it was it was a one of
those I think interesting phone calls
where it's like um uh you know where you
get a call which could be along the
lines of you know the crocodile a
crocodile ate my my floppy disk can you
send me another one type thing but this
was a uh you know there's an astronaut
with a space station and you know the
needs this thing to run and it's like
just turn on the television and you'll
see that this is a real news story so
okay that that all got resolved and
unfortunately we were able to to give um
uh give the ground control people the
you know some different code to type in
and the thing ran on the Russian
computer and Mike managed to get quite a
long way in solving the the equations of
motion I think the bad thing was that
the Russian ground controllers who were
uh kind of the people you know it was
their space station so you couldn't like
break it
um well like no no just because you
solved these equations and you say we
can do this and this and this that is
not our procedure you can't do that you
know we must follow our procedures and
so the thing kept spinning for another
day or so but eventually that their
procedures were followed and all was
well
um but so that was a that was kind of an
exotic story of of um uh kind of the
copy protection of old
um
it's a lot easier now the uh uh you know
you can download freewolf and engine for
developers or something and it doesn't
doesn't ask you anything
um
let's see
um
Rob is saying that they
came online so to speak when they needed
two CDs for games I thought that was a
pain right
um
oh yes after shock says I might be
misremembering but I think we put a
piece of masking tape on flubby disks to
prevent copy protection uh I think what
you're thinking of is on a floppy disk
there's a little slider that is the
thing that determines whether the disc
is writable or not
and I think if you and so so you can
kind of slide that to make a hole and
then the disc is not writable anymore
and I think people did copy protection
stuff that was based on that that uh
sort of read you know that right
protection uh thing on the physical disk
I think that's the um uh
uh that that's that's the kind of kind
of thing
um
question here from proud
thoughts and internet pseudonymity and
its history
it's interesting I I you know
okay when I use the Opera net
which was the Forerunner of the internet
and I started using that in 1976.
um it had 512 hosts I believe all with
numerical IDs many of those hosts were
not publicly accessible they were things
like the North American Air Defense
computer and so on
um they were you know you would you
could get to a login prompt but you
didn't know a password and um that was
the end of it
um but there were computers that were
publicly accessible and
um one that I used a bunch was the
project Mac the multi-access computer uh
system at MIT and that system had uh
you had a login and I remember when I
went to that computer for the first time
in 1976 using it over the arpanet from
England
um and you know the Opera net was I used
the Opera net because I I worked at a
government lab in England which had a
connection to that it wasn't like you
could like Dial It Up from home type
thing
um the uh uh when I went to that
computer it said you know log in and it
said create a login
and so I tried to create the login SW
because those are my initials and it
said that's been taken
so I went and I created s wolf
instead and that for many years was my
my login
um but that computer didn't know me from
anything I mean didn't have any idea I
was a you know whatever a 16 year old
kid in England didn't know it I doubt
that it even logged
I I very strongly doubt that it knew uh
sort of the originating address over the
over the Internet over the up in that
that any requests were coming from so
you know right then I was Anonymous I
mean in in uh I don't think
that my no I'm pretty certain that that
computer never knew my actual name and
never asked for it
um so you know that came very early
and I think the um the concept of kind
of a a handle independent of one's
actual name was sort of forced on people
by the technology because I don't know
how how many letters there could have
been in my login but not that many and
certainly there wouldn't have been
spaces and things like that in the login
um at that time and uh you know I was
just actually just found
um because I've been doing this research
on my own sort of history of the Second
World thermodynamics I found some email
I was a consultant at Bell labs
um in
1983-ish time frame and interacted a
bunch with the Unix group at that time
and uh I found um I happened to find a
piece of mail about random number
generators actually that I had sent to
somebody and somebody else and sent back
to me and one of the addresses on there
was research exclam Ken
so at that time addresses didn't have
their form of blah blah blah at blah
blah blah although the at sign was
already used back in the in the project
Mac computer
um but for slightly different purposes
but along with along with usernames but
at that time this was the uucp system
the Unix to Unix copy program being used
for email and what you would see in an
email address like my email address at
that time was um uh IAS X Glam Sun
x-clam Swift I think
um which is was Institute for advanced
study x-clam an x-clamp and then it was
it was basically the routing of how you
got
where which machine you had to call up
by phone to to send the message to next
and so you would have these sequences of
of uh of descriptors for things
um but anyway research exclam Ken was
Ken Thompson
um who I knew back in in those days
um who was uh one of the creators of
Unix and and the C programming language
um and uh actually I'm remembering now
Joe Condon who was another person
involved in that group I believe was a
was somebody who had built a chess
computer it's also the person I believe
who invented the touch tone dialing
system there's also a person who was
very proud of having a machine that was
some kind of referred to as sort of the
black hole or something which was a a
machine where you could dial into where
you could dial into it I think and it
would dial out to a phone number you
know any phone number anywhere in the
world type thing and and not Bill
anybody for it I mean to be fair that
was at a time when when um you know the
Bell Labs had created kind of the whole
telephone switching infrastructure and
these successive levels of ESS the
electronic switching system whatever it
was you know ESS five six seven I think
it had got to in those days esr7 which
were telephone exchanges that would deal
with 10 million uh lines and um uh so
you know that that was the the folks
who'd created that
I guess there was a version of Unix
called Unix RT the real-time version of
Unix which was running on the on the
whatever they were 3b2 I think they were
called computers that were in those
telephone switches uh which were a kind
of a custom-made set of computers made
by by
um uh by Bell labs
um
okay let me see
uh
yeah well perhaps talking about phone
systems and and blue boxes I think and
things like this you know the thing was
back in the day in the 80s
you know the only way you could sort of
communicate with sort of the most
powerful computer around which was the
phone system was through dialing numbers
and originally it was actually dialing
with rotary phones then that sort of
transitioned in the
um
late 80s I guess
no no no no 70s but by the time I was in
the US which is 1978 I never had a
rotary dial phone in the U.S I never had
a touch-dialing phone in England either
so so I think they had come in in the US
by by 1970 oh no no that's not right I
had a I'm wrong I'm wrong I I had a a um
my home phone I got a um in those days
you rented your physical phone from the
Bell System so to speak and I got a I
chose to get a touchstone phone
um as soon as I could but I remember in
a very retro kind of world I remember
dialing up the the machine the tip the
terminal interface processor for the
Opera net
um on a rotary dial phone and then
connecting through a modem through an
acoustic coupled modem and then getting
to the alternate so to speak so that was
still a rotary dial phone so I guess
that they were still around in the late
70s maybe they disappeared in the early
80s but you know on a rotary dial phone
as the as the rotary dial clicks around
but it just makes it a different number
of bips for each different number as the
dial turns around that amount to
correspond to dialing you know that's
why you know area code 212 is the area
code for New York because that's kind of
the the top area code so to speak and
that was the area code that was fastest
to dial and if you were somewhere where
the the people who allocated area codes
thought there wouldn't be much
population you would get you know the
eight whatever it was area code
um because that was a slower to dial
area code Los Angeles got 213 and and
Etc et cetera et cetera those were the
the big population places got
um the uh the kind of the fastest area
codes like like San Francisco was four
and five and that was a little bit you
know down scale from from the bigger
population centers Boston I guess even
more downscale was 617. uh yeah that's a
terrible thing about old people like me
is that that I actually remember area
codes
um and when I see a number now you know
it's it's like all numbers have been
scrambled because everybody just has the
cell phone from when they grew up
somewhere or something and so you can't
tell anything from a phone number but
but I sort of have an instinctive oh
yeah that's a Los Angeles phone number
something but anyways by the time
then there was Touchstone dialing and
you would be sending data through you
know you're sending data to the phone
system and the question is what can you
actually send and it was the case that
that there were all these weird codes
that you could type in that would sort
of switch on and off different
characteristics of the phone system and
so on I remember uh this was a thing
from from actually from England I
remember this was 1982 January of 82 I
think
um I was in England working on a
software project
and needed to transfer code to the US
and um uh it was a Sunday evening I
think and um I was you know had an
acoustic coupled modem and I was trying
to connect it and do a international
call to a computer in the US
um to transfer this data and it just
didn't work just didn't work and and
part of the problem was in those days it
tended to be that there was sort of half
duplex that is um uh only one person
could be talking at a time type phone
calls where where the thing would um
um oh and that's right and there was
also Echo canceling because what would
happen is there would be something where
you would say something and then if
there wasn't Echo canceling somewhere at
sort of the other end of the line there
would be sort of a an echo of that and
that would come back and it would be
very confusing and so the um in any case
the bottom line was the acoustic cover
modem could not handle sending data
across a transatlantic phone call
because the translator phone call has
all kinds of echo canceling and half
duplex and all kinds of other things set
and so it's very frustrating it's like
what are we going to do and so we start
calling you know the operator because in
those days you could just dial the
operator
um and um
and some actual human would pick up and
so the operator and said trying to make
this transatlantic call and it doesn't
work and we're trying to do transfer
data the operator is like I don't have
any idea what you're talking about but
I'll transfer you to somebody else to
transfer you to somebody else we got
through three or four levels of people
and eventually we get some some chap who
was um who was oh yes you know I don't
know whether he knew you know because
they've been transferred through so many
places I have no idea whether he knew
you know that it was a consumer versus
an internal person at the phone system I
have no idea who's talking to he said oh
yes no problem just dial you know this
this this this this some string of five
numbers that will switch off the echo
canceling and set this and this and you
know route you over this kind of line
should work there they try it it works
perfectly and I think what what became
clear that person was actually sort of
the chief engineer on duty at that time
in England sort of dealing with the
phone system and somehow we'd gone
through enough enough levels of of you
know take me to your leader so to speak
that we reach that person who were just
able to say there's just the string of
numbers you type in and that will get
you a line that will be appropriate for
this kind of data transfer I mean who
knows well that was what sort of the
official phone company usage was
supposed to be but but that was sort of
a uh you know that was how it worked is
that you would dial some some
complicated sequence of numbers and I
think in um uh I think there were lots
of sort of um uh you know military type
situations in the US where it's like you
know dial this number and dial the next
string of 14 numbers and you'll reach
you know some person in um uh in some
critical place in you know in the U.S
military infrastructure or something
um uh I think that's um uh but the other
thing was that the billing mechanism was
also based on these kinds of tones and
so these blue boxes that people made
were things that would sort of fake out
the billing mechanism uh for the phone
system and let you make free phone calls
and things like that
um
ah cap is saying their father used to
program on the edsac II that's really
that's before my time where you need a
paper tape with holes to load the
compiler than your program absolutely
the first computer I used absolutely I
used paper tape I still have a bunch of
that paper tape
um it's uh the computer I used used
eight-hole paper tape which was pretty
common
um now the question is because I've been
doing this history about the second
order of thermodynamics I wrote a
program in 1973 when I was 13 or
whatever that was one of my first big
programs that was intended to do a
simulation of molecules bouncing around
idealized molecules bouncing around and
I wrote that for a computer called the
Elliott 903 and that can that that
program is I wrote it on paper tape I
have a bunch of paper tapes I don't know
whether I have a copy of that program
because I don't know what's on the paper
tapes I have and the question is how do
you read a paper tape in today's world
and so we've been looking around just in
the last week or two for how do you read
a paper tape and uh so far we've
determined that the Computer History
Museum has a um has a paper take reader
um but you know it's to the point you
know for example nine track tape reader
we bought one of those off eBay a few
years ago but a paper tape reader that
technology in 40 years that technology
is old enough that you can't you can't
buy one of those off eBay at least we
couldn't find one
um and um in fact my best guess is the
best way to read that paper tape is to
just lay it out on you know laid out in
strips photograph it and do image
processing on it
um now for the particular paper tape I
have
it has an extra wrinkle because I wrote
the loader that I used for paper tape
which was the thing that would take the
the data on the paper tape and load it
into the memory of the computer the
computer I used the way it worked is you
would set it had switches toggle
switches and you would set an initial
address that the computers that was the
initial value of the program counter or
what in British English was called the
sequence control register you would set
the sequence control register to a
particular value and you set that on a
bunch of toggle switches then you would
press I remember it was a button with a
yellow light behind it that was the jump
button that you would press jump and
then the computer would start executing
at the place in its memory where the
program at the place in its memory that
corresponded to the address you'd set on
the toggle switches and by default the
computer started it had 8192 words of
memory and it had 18-bit words of memory
and its default initial location was at
8181 actually what it had was it had its
so-called initial instructions what
would now be called its bootloader was
stored between 8181 and 8192s so I guess
there were 11 instructions long that was
the default thing that the computer
would do on um on on starting and um
the uh the thing that um uh so you would
okay so you press jump and I guess you
you could enter the the the the
um the address or
that's right you would normally enter
8181 and it would start running its
initial instructions for which it didn't
need a tape otherwise and those initial
instructions right the initial
instructions would start reading a tape
through the optical tape reader and um
that from the optical tape reader it
would get what it needed to start
actually running whatever program you
were trying to run but what what the
first thing you would have to do is it
would start just reading literally the
beginning of the tape but the next
question was how was the rest of the
tape encoded after it had the initial
loader at the beginning of the tape that
said how to read the tape how is the
tape encoded so one of the big problems
with that computer was that it would be
a tape punch where it would punch out
the paper tape and it would get little
pieces of confetti and one would
regularly get little pieces of confetti
stuck in the holes of the paper tape it
was particularly bad when there was
Mylar tape you know this plasticized
tape that was for more sort of permanent
programs you could punch mylar tapers as
well as paper tape and the tape punch
and Mylar tape just would get static
electricity and it would pick up
um pick up little little you know pieces
of confetti and so on and every time it
will pick up a piece of confetti
obviously the computer was just blindly
reading the data that was on the tape
and so if there was a piece of confetti
there a bit would be wrong and your
program wouldn't work so it's kind of a
nuisance and it would be the case that
that the default loader I believe had a
horizontal checksum where it would read
the whole paper tape and it would have a
binary uh attracted to it that was just
taking you know the the even or odd
number of holes that were supposed to be
in the tape so you'd read this whole
paper tape and the paper tape would run
through the the optical tape reader it
wound up in a in a wooden bin on the
side of the computer and it would be in
a big mess and one of the big sort of
technical things you had to be able to
do was take the end of the paper tape
and there was a little rolling thing
where you would roll it up and make it
into a nice a nice piece of paper tape
again
um and uh
the um but but anyway so it was super
annoying because you would read this
whole giant program and there'd be some
con piece of confetti that got stuck in
the tape halfway through and the thing
would just read to the hook till the end
it would say Boop it didn't work
um and uh uh yes my my scrapbook online
has a picture of some paper tape that
comes from that very um very computer
um but in any case the um I
uh as an enterprising 13 year old or
something decided to write my own paper
tape loader and so I I guess I invented
what we call error correcting codes and
I thought it was kind of clever it would
it would read through and it would have
these blocks and there would be the um
uh the actual data and there would be
um it would be interwoven with in the
way there are collecting codes work it
will be interwoven with the check
information rather than the check
information being all the way at the end
of the tape it was interwoven with the
data and so what would happen is if
there was a piece of confetti there or
something it would just stop because it
would find out it failed its error
correction it failed it's it's checking
and error checking and it would just
stop in the in the tape reader and so
then what you would do is you would pull
the tape back a few feet in the tape
reader and then you know get rid of the
piece of confetti and started reading
again and so then I had this clever
scheme which I now don't remember it's
full detail for re-synchronizing the
tape reading because you pull it back
and obviously you're just pulling it
some distance you won't you didn't know
how the thing was aligned it wasn't like
it was the beginning of the tape so I
had some scheme for for having it be
able to Auto auto determine where it was
in the in the sequence okay so this was
I was I was pleased with my paper tape
loader and a lot of people started using
my paper tape loader as well so I
probably my first um distributed program
because I sent it into the company that
made the computer and I think I think it
ended up getting used elsewhere as well
um but uh
in any case the um the problem with my
paper tape loader is that that means
that it is not the case that I can just
read the bit sequences off the tapes I
have they are encoded with my paper tape
loader I guess the loader is on the tape
so now that I think about it if we have
an emulator for the Elliott 903 we
should be able to read what's on the
tape actually
um but it means that we can't like just
expect that it's plain uh character
codes for the characters you know if it
was a source code program so someone was
asking
um
uh
um
how many lines of code was my my first
simulation I don't remember I remember
that the paper tape was um not huge it
was maybe um two or three inches across
when you rolled it up so I should work
out how long it was I I think it never
really worked properly which is very
frustrating and I realized much later I
probably discovered some interesting
phenomena but I had no idea what it was
and I you know I probably discovered the
phenomenon of being able to make
Randomness from simple rules because I'd
sort of simplified the rules to the
point where they were simple enough that
I could program them in a similar
language on this computer
um
any case the uh okay maybe uh
that was a long discussion of of um
distribution
things and I I don't know and and you
know in the case of that computer the
way you would distribute software is you
would um uh have a program have a paper
tape you read it through the tape reader
and as it was reading the tape punch was
punching a copy of the of the tape I
mean it's kind of interesting that these
early computers was very physicalized
the the production of a copy is very
similar to what biology has to do where
again it's you know you make a copy it's
very physicalized you know obviously
with molecules that you're making
another tape and it is funny that you
know the the whole uh DNA story and RNA
story and ribosomes and things like that
is it is quite strange that it's so
similar to sort of our early computers
because computers today if somebody says
oh you're encoding the program as a tape
it's like you know to a modern young
person it's like a tape a tape what is a
tape
um the tape has nothing to do with uh
you know what what are you talking about
a tape for a computer I mean it's it's
just got RAM and things like this
um and it so happens that biology is
using the kind of 1950s 1960s style of
encoding uh information apparently on a
tape now I suspect biology isn't that
isn't the only thing biology is doing I
suspect biology is also storing
information in these kind of dynamic
networks of reactions and things which
are a different story but that's for
another day
um
all right let's see maybe maybe one or
two more questions here and then should
wrap up for today uh
um
let's see Parker asks how is the central
Hub of science changed geographically
over time and what are the reasons for
the change
well
depends what you mean by science I mean
you know it really helps to be able to
write things down so you know ancient
Babylon good place for science to start
the astrologers of ancient Babylon were
sort of probably the first scientists
and you know observing the heavens
looking at entrails of goats or whatever
they were
um you know these were these were things
where they didn't really know what was
predictable what was not but that was
kind of the very first sort of place of
Science and Babylon was a big trading
center so it was a place where people
came through there I mean I think that
you know there are a lot more Babylonian
scientific
tablets for example than there are
Egyptian I don't know of too many in
fact I'm not even sure
I know
well let's see the Rind papyrus
which is an early example of kind of
mathematical exercises that's an
Egyptian thing so maybe there was some
amount of um of of Science in Egypt to
math and Egypt I think it was much more
a Babylonian kind of tradition it then
really moved to Athens and the Greek
tradition or the Athenian Empire so to
speak places like Alexandria in Egypt
and so on were big when the with the
Library of Alexandria people like Euclid
worked there
um then you know the whole sort of
extended Greek uh civilization you know
Archimedes and Sicily things like this
that was that was the next big place for
Science and I think that there are
civilizations that have more of an
inclination towards kind of intellectual
matters and learning and so on than
others and you know it then passed from
there sort of from Greek civilization
that got kind of was sort of the the
fancy stuff for the for Romans although
the Romans themselves were less interest
but I think in the science story it was
more kind of a Greek tradition that that
survived within that that world
then
you know after the fall of the Roman
Empire
um the there were you know at the time
there were all these books of of
Aristotle Archimedes all these kinds of
people that were being passed down by
copying and that really passed to uh uh
monasteries and a lot of um uh and a lot
of that knowledge got preserved in the
Arab world
um and uh
um and then kind of I would say my
impression is it re-emerged in a
somewhat distributed way in you know
there's a particular Monastery here
which has sort of kept this knowledge
from the past when universities came on
the scene and universities were were
kind of creatures of Western
Civilization I mean they were very you
know in the 1200s when universities in
bologna and Oxford and and so on uh sort
of in Paris uh started off they were
very uh kind of you know for the
training of clerics and things like this
it was kind of a a Christian tradition
and kind of Western Civilization story
and that was I guess
the um
uh
you know that was more a theology story
I think even not an Alchemy and things
story at the time and I don't know when
science
um
there was a lot of science that was oh
yeah I mean the other the other big big
place for science by that time by
certainly by the 1400s was was Italy
Pisa Venice things like places like that
these were Merchant centers actually
even in 1200 Fibonacci and Pisa had um
uh was you know that was a trading Hub
and at a trading Hub people needed to
compute things with money and that meant
that math was worthwhile and you know
commerce was a driver of of certain
kinds of scientific advance and so I
think that was um you know that that led
to that that and I think then probably
one can really trace the the sort of the
the hotbeds of science probably moved
around with the hotbeds of Commerce I
mean the Netherlands for a while London
um uh these kinds of places you know I
think sort of the the economic
Prosperity was was a big thing I mean
then
you know it's a little hard to trace uh
well in in Europe we get to more Modern
Times And um you know there's a
tremendous concentration of what is
modern sort of science came out of the
western civilization tradition which was
very concentrated in Europe
um really that's that's the place where
it was happening
um I would say that the the sort of
there was some amount of math that
happened in India China
Etc other places but I would say that
the the the sort of the main thrust of
what has become sort of the the current
tradition of science is very pretty
pristly pretty Western Civilization
oriented and certainly by the 1600s that
was a story sort of pretty that was a a
France Germany England story of of kind
of the um uh the development of kind of
mathematical science events I think
by the time I mean things kind of
blobbed around there were different
traditions in different places that was
kind of in the 1800s there was kind of
the Continental Europe tradition and it
was ahead in some ways and there was the
British tradition and it was ahead in
other ways and these kind of blobed
around for a while
um I think then uh kind of the um
uh you know for a while late 1800s I
mean in different fields I I think you
know my impression is Germany for
example was very big in things like
chemistry physics
um England maybe had um
well let's see I mean it just you know
there were there were lots of things
being done in different places I think
that that a lot of uh one question was
how were people doing these these things
like science because most people didn't
do it as a profession most people did it
because they were had another means of
support they were independently wealthy
they had some other business running
um it was uh you know and so it was done
by those kinds of people or they were
part of a court somewhere they were part
of uh you know they were advisors to a
court or whatever else and that so that
sort of depended on on how those things
were set up and whether you know the
king at the time was interested in uh
you know and having science folk around
or not and I think that you know that
led to a lot of sort of detailed
um
you know motion of scientists I would
say that the the thing that allowed
science to be pretty itinerant for a
long time was that well most learning
was written in Latin and Latin was kind
of a universal language of learning
known to the folks who were doing that
and that finally started to disintegrate
in the 1600s and that's what led people
like leibniz to be so keen on inventing
mathematical notation because he saw
that as a way to to sort of keep
mathematics at least coherent between
different countries and not sort of
fragment it across things written in in
English or German or whatever else and I
think that um uh you know that that was
a thing that probably more regionalized
um science
um although it it is the case that the
sort of diffusion time for people is
long compared is short compared to the
time scale for substantial changes in
science and so that's tended to mean
that there has been mostly sort of one
worldwide world wide science rather than
a lot of fragmented pieces I say that
but but for example during the Cold War
there was at least a certain amount of
Divergence between sort of Soviet let's
say physics and American physics
although with a lot of you know effort
to knit those together by having Soviet
journals translated into English and I
suspect American journals translated
into Russian though I don't actually
know that
um and and so I think um uh
yeah that's that's that's been a a thing
there
um
the um
uh
let's see
another sorry I just noticed a question
here from Harry do you know if there's
ever been a copy protection scheme for
paper tapes no there won't have been
because well I say that I say that I say
that
um
you know
people certainly put commercial data on
paper tapes I don't think anybody
worried about it at that time and I know
uh some friends of mine from from high
school who were had all kinds of sort of
computer security exploits that they did
on the computer that um that we had that
was this paper tape based computer and I
think it involved uh what would now be
called sort of dumpster diving of
finding sort of pieces of paper tape
that have been discarded and so on that
had data on them so I think in those
days people didn't think about that I
mean I don't think the idea of
encrypting a paper tape for example was
completely to me at least at the time
was utterly unknown
um I think people when they would do
commercial okay so related to paper
tapes with Telex machines which is
usually a five-hole paper tape which
were things where you would basically
dial on the phone and the paper tape was
just a way of sending your data through
more quickly so you wouldn't be sort of
sending a telegraph type message at the
moment when you're already connected on
the phone line
um now Telex machines
um they didn't use codes like that but
they did have commercial codes and what
would happen is companies would have
these code books and it would be code
words and so people would translate you
know it would say you know uh the fish
is in the ocean or something that
translates into you know there'll be a
shipment that will arrive in this place
at that time or something that not
enough data there but but they would
have these code books that would be a
way of sending sort of encoded messages
um in that kind of very very
straightforward kind of fashion and I
think on Telex machines people may have
used
uh possibly they may have used things
like Caesar ciphers or Vineyard ciphers
where where you're basically just saying
you know to every letter A you know to
every letter adds six to the position of
the letter or add six to this letter and
six plus two six plus two plus two
Etc to success of letters
um
let's see Philip observes there's a link
between training collegium and the
original role of most western
universities and the growth of early
modern science uh for sure I mean that
was the that was the reason people
thought University should exist I mean
later on there were law schools medical
schools things like that I think you
know that the whole question of what's
Education 4 has been something that has
kind of sort of I think
gets to be important in modern times but
public education like K-12 education you
know it's like train people so they can
join the Army train people so they can
be part of a democracy those are trained
people so they are suitable to work in
factories in the industrial revolution
these are kind of the origins well that
was sort of the origin K-12 education
University education was a much more
Elite business I mean you know even when
I was and I'm not that ancient but even
when I was in high school in the early
19th early to mid 1970s
um in England uh you know I went to this
very fancy high school called Eaton and
um there were I don't know what fraction
of kids were going to college from there
at that time but I would guess was on
the order of two-thirds
so and I and I think a little bit
earlier it was on the order of maybe a
third or a quarter now the people who
were in The the kind of the the king's
Scholars crowd which was the sort of the
the scholarship kids who were the more
academic crowd of which I was one
um my guess is that a much larger
fraction of those people probably close
to 100 went on to University but of the
of the other folk the so-called operans
the people of the town so to speak
um who were not part of the the um the
sort of the the original thing endowed
by the King Henry the oh my gosh sixth
maybe
um the uh in 1450 ish
no 14 I don't remember that of that yeah
1450ish I think
um
but uh of those people the you know in
England at that time uh
you know I would say a minority probably
went on to college but in the 1960s
probably a minority of the
non-scholarship kids went on to college
and what do they do they
uh went to what was usually called
manage the family estates
they went to join the Army
uh they went into uh various kinds of uh
of family businesses and so on which
were trade businesses or whatever else
and going to college was sort of this
irrelevant intellectual kind of thing
it only became you know it's only in
very recent times that sort of this
Universal college or it's not really
Universal even now but this This Much
More Much broader sort of uh uh use of
college and I suppose in the in the US
it probably came in maybe came in after
World War II with the GI Bill and things
like this I'm not sure
um but uh uh and you know it is a good
question that you know what is the role
of these different forms of Education in
society what's the role of the
universities I think the idea that
universities are a place where research
happens is kind of a was a sort of was
always an add-on it was always like it's
mostly about teaching but by the way
people do research too and then
Government funding of research came in
in the US in the
1930s and 40s I think
um and uh and big time after uh the
1950s
um and that sort of uh put together a
bunch of the sort of research function
the teaching function I mean it's a good
question whether universities should
have and do have as their mission the
preservation of Knowledge from
generation to generation from the 1200s
on or whether the universities have the
mission to you know create new knowledge
and feed the new stuff to the next to
the kids who are there what it is I mean
I I tend to think that there is a great
value to preserving the knowledge of our
civilization
um and that it's kind of a mistake and
well here I am doing a live stream about
history so obviously uh we all believe
somewhat in in the value of History
um and uh
uh it's you know I tend to think that's
that's a part of the mission and I think
for a long time in the history of
universities that really was seen as the
mission was was just the the the the the
sort of the preservation of knowledge
across across generations and so on
um
you know I I'm I'm being asked here from
spare about thoughts on different
methods of storing information in terms
of resilience over long time skills you
know I I keep on being asked this
because I I make use of a lot of
historical archives and so archivists uh
who know I'm in the tech business will
say Hey you know it'd be really great if
you guys could make a better archiving
system yeah we're going to try and do
that because I'm going to try to do that
for my own archive and hopefully we'll
make something that other people can use
too but people ask you know how should
they store the data and my statement is
the only data that I've been able to
consistently keep alive is data that's
been in online storage anything that's
off on a tape a disk a you know a quartz
crystal thing I don't know how to read
that stuff like I'm talking about paper
tapes and that's a 40-year span and I
don't know how to read the paper Tape 40
years later so big lose if I put the
stuff on paper tape
um I have to say that things that are on
paper which can be scanned those have
done okay it's like I I know
something random fact about medical
records if you look at um uh the U.S
army for example the medical records
from World War II which were all kept on
paper are alive and well the medical
records from the Gulf War I'm told are
kind of non-existent because they were
on computers and the computers were when
they came back from the war the
computers were wiped and so it was not
as robust as a storage method as just
stick it on paper put it in a you know
put it in them uh you know put it in
some storage facility somewhere so I
tend to think that um I mean I've had
the experience of reading
um magnetic tapes
discs and so on from 40 something years
ago
I think we've usually been able to do it
I don't think the magnetic
um I I don't think they've been
demagnetized over that period of time so
I think that's been okay the main
problem is the format and uh and just
the physicality of how do you read a you
know a cassette tape for a Apollo domain
computer or something or whatever they
were called is that the name I forget
um
from 1983
well it's not easy to do that you know
there has to be a sort of a chain of
things that involves you know
reconditioned machines brought off eBay
type thing so you know I think that um
in terms of
of uh uh you know other things where in
principle you could read it you know I
think things that have been etched into
various kinds of materials in principle
you will be able to read it
um is it easy to read no the only stuff
that's easy to read is the online stuff
I mean there's an interesting wrinkle on
this with blockchains because you know a
blockchain has the feature that in order
to
you know when you put new things onto
the blockchain in order to validate the
new things the whole of the rest of the
blockchain has to be valid and so in a
sense those who add want to add new
things to the head of the blockchain
have to or the tail the modern tail of
the blockchain or something have to be
maintaining the head they have to be
maintaining the earliest blocks in order
to maintain the Integrity of the hashes
that they get for their modern blocks so
blockchain is an interesting case it's a
kind of pay it backwards type situation
where the people who are adding now and
sort of putting effort into doing things
on blockchain now are necessarily
preserving the data that was put onto
the blockchain earlier so it's an
interesting kind of model for sort of
force preservation of course that
assumes that the blockchain doesn't just
go completely Belly Up and people don't
just forget about it
um and you know the number of copies of
blockchains is not very large I mean
it's maybe thousands at most
um and and some are much much smaller
than that so it's not the case that it's
like oh we will be able to find this and
we'll be able to find it forever more I
mean I would say that the um
you know in my own experience
um of uh of archived material
yeah I mean one of the problems is you
sometimes you have uh archive tapes we
don't usually store all the diffs in
fact we're just trying to work out a
better scheme right now to basically we
have a bunch of archive tapes and their
daily weekly monthly backups and it's a
question of kind of aligning those
properly
um all right I should wrap up in a
moment here
um
uh Harry is commenting that um from
Babylonian times uh canare form is
preserved because it was stamped on clay
tablets they say all the good stuff
science poetry was written on material
like hides and Papyrus that in age well
I actually
um
uh didn't know that
um
there is a decent amount of math in in
Canary form tablets there's a decent
amount of mathematical tables and there
is a
uh
yeah there's certainly exercises done
because the scribal schools in ancient
Babylon were I believe teaching people
to to um to write on on clay tablets
that were soft at the time when they
were being you know when they had a
little
you know wooden styluses that they were
using in them and then they they baked
them in the sun I I was I was not aware
of a sort of a a
um uh a non-surviving track though that
might have existed
um SS is commenting that the Dutch East
India company has records and paper that
exist from the 1600s and 1700s yeah I
mean that you know you go look in the
British museum for example there's all
kinds of interesting documents that are
sitting right there that come from that
period of time I think I think in the
you know I think the legal cases in
England are still extant from that
period of time I know I have a friend
who's a I think a fifth generation
lawyer in England and he was very proud
um a few years ago that he got to cite a
precedent
from like the 1300s and I'm kind of
thinking that that precedent must have
existed on paper somewhere in some uh in
some archives somewhere otherwise it
wouldn't really otherwise nobody would
know that case law precedent
um
well let's see I think I should probably
wrap up here is there anything else on
these these topics that I could maybe um
talk about a little bit
um
Aaron is asking about um
uh
access to Scientific data and it's
sharing over time
you know scientists are usually pretty
bad at sharing their data and always
have been
I think
my own efforts at providing sort of open
code and so on and and having a a
I mean look in the in the past
yeah sharing has not been a strong suit
for a lot of scientists I mean when the
solution to the cubic equation was
coming in in 1500 or so there was this
whole Giant uh sort of flap about the
fact that this uh you know between
cardano and Ferrari and and I forget the
names of all these other people who had
who claimed you know I have the solution
to the cubic I can demonstrate it to you
I can solve a cubic in front of your
eyes but I'm not going to tell you what
the formula is that that's been a thing
forever and ever and hasn't changed and
you know when people say oh they've been
all kinds of efforts in the US for
federally funded research for example
for people to put their data online to
make their data available yeah well
um we've been involved in some of those
efforts and the sad thing is that
people
you know will usually just say well here
it is it's like a like a legal filing of
some kind it's a big mess and it's
really quite unusable
I mean one of the things with Wolfram
language and this thing we call our data
framework is we actually have a
representation of all these different
kinds of things in the world whether
it's a geolocation or a species of
animal or whatever else we have a
standardized representation of those
things and once you have data that uses
that in our computational language then
you can actually get to use it in lots
of other places and so you've gone to
some effort to make our data repository
be something where you can once you have
data in the data repository and it takes
some effort to get it into that sort of
computable form then there's a chance to
use it elsewhere and and then it really
becomes a seriously useful thing where
you can actually make use of the data
elsewhere but most of the time with with
notable exceptions I mean there are
there are lots of government agencies in
the US NASA being one of them NIH is
another one where where there are big
data sources uh Federal Reserve is
another one where there are sort of big
standardized data sources that are
highly used full and and well well
accessible so to speak
you know I think
the
the main story of this has to do with in
the U.S
uh sort of from the get-go a lot of data
was sort of the government you know
whatever it is by the people for the
people or something it's like the
government data is going to be
accessible from the Census Data to lots
of other things it was very much a U.S
driven concept to have sort of
accessible government data in other
countries
absolutely not that same tradition I
mean I you know I could tell you many
stories in the UK for example oh a good
example
um
uh the Ordnance survey the the mapping
agency in the UK
um you know it always said it's maps are
copyrighted and they're Crown copyright
and you know they're not copyable my
friend Steve Coast back whenever it was
20 years ago or something now
um decided to have this project called
openstreetmap where he got people to
make uh kind of by you know uploading
their GPS data and so on to sort of make
um open maps of as it's turned out the
whole world and as it's turned out
that's the the foundation that's used
for for lots and lots of mapping that's
done around the world but that was a
consequence of the fact that in the UK
um you know the maps the standard
government Maps were considered
um uh copyrighted I mean I remember that
come
and was it about 12 years ago or
something now we were trying to use
British tide tables which were you know
copyright the admiralty and then there
were tide tables which they were
considered secret and it was just a
whole a very different attitude towards
data and data sharing from from
governments other than the US government
I mean there's been
um uh you know even in the European
Union uh different approach I mean
there's a lot of stuff there where in
the US the data is free and the European
Union it's it's quite expensive data
um that is not not prop not to not not
readily available it's an interesting
trade-off
um and uh
um
um
that's uh but I think um
um you know the challenge
of
open data is
it's really no good to have something
like my paper tape
no it's it's got to be data in some
computable understandable transferable
form and as I say a bunch of our
technology is kind of I think the the
most advanced in terms of making that
possible
um but uh that's a different story
all right I should wrap up and uh go
back to my day job here
um and uh thanks for asking all kinds of
interesting things and um
I look uh forward to uh
being with you again on another another
live stream uh well I'll be doing
another one of these in two weeks and um
my other one on Friday Etc et cetera et
cetera anyway
um thanks for joining me and uh bye for
now